[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka the white weirdo and this video
we're breaking down black widow
the brand new marvel movie stars
scarlett johansson and it very much
feels like a closing of the book on
natasha romanov's story
the film culminates with a big
cliffhanger that sets up a showdown
between elena belova and hawkeye
and maybe if nathan have been a better
cliffhanger we wouldn't have been here
in the first place thank you i'm here
all week now
we open with nat's childhood in 1995.
that is part of a spy family made up of
her father alexi
mother molina and sister elena this
movie is very much about family
and i was half expecting dom toretto to
show up and catch black widow falling
from the
sky on the bonnet of his car now
interestingly nat's origin very much
mirrors val's backstory
as in the comics she was part of a
sleeper cell family working inside an
anti-communism movement
this was for the organization leviathan
and clearly she's not adverse to
manipulating people
and this may be because she herself was
manipulated when she was younger
there's very much an idea of ruined
childhoods in this film
and nats is destroyed when her father
infiltrates the north institute
in order to steal shield secrets from
the hydra front
they have one last meal together before
leaving the country and this idea of
final suppers appears at several points
in the film
now the info he stole included a map of
the basal ganglia
which is the part of the brain that
controls decision making and choices
hydra of course were masters at
manipulating this and it explains how
they were able to control bucky's mind
in the winter soldier
the family have to flee and after
landing in the russian ally country of
cuba
nad and her sister are enlisted into the
red room program
this is a female assassin division
headed up by a man named drakov
who wants to create an army of all girl
assassins
we learned that during the mission in
budapest sorry budapest
nat made an attempt on his life and his
daughter was also apparently killed
during this
however she survived and drakov
transformed her into the taskmaster
an almost unstoppable assassin that is
able to perfectly mimic her opponent's
fighting styles
now i know a lot of people yet will be
annoyed by this reveal
especially as it reduces one of the best
characters in marvel
to being a mindless machine in the
comics taskmaster was responsible for
training several people
and the change from anthony masters to
antonio drakov
is probably going to leave a lot of
people asking but why
now taskmaster is played by olga
kurolenko and what's funny is
she's one of the only russian actors in
the film but she gets one line
whilst everyone else is putting on this
stereotypical accent
anyway the main plot takes place right
after the events of civil war
if you cast your mind back to that
you'll remember that she stunned black
panther
when he attempted to get stephen bucky
at the airport and after this she was
warned by tony stark that secretary ross
would be coming for her
though she went on the run and mirroring
this her sister elena does
at the same time too it turns out that
when nat defected to the west
her sister was put through an updated
run of the red room that used the stolen
north institute
studies to brainwash it whilst out on a
mission in morocco
elena is sprayed with red mist that
wipes the brainwashing from her and this
gives her back her free will
she realizes how evil the red room is
and reaches out to her sister in order
to help bring
everything down now interestingly the
person who sprays her with the red mist
is called oxana
a character from the black widow comics
that was heavily tied in with the red
widow
the story of the film also seems to be
based upon the deathless frenzy
which was a chemical serum from the
comics that could highly alter someone's
behavior
now sadly i'm not sure how much this
brainwashing plot works
and when that isn't able to kill draco
because of pheromones
it's bad writing in my opinion i really
wish that they'd handled it with there
not being any brainwashing at all
and elena simply saw her sister stand up
to the government during the events of
civil war
which inspired her to do the same thing
in her country this would give her far
more agency in my opinion
and would make natasha's legacy a lot
stronger as we could see how she
inspired others to do good
rather than simply having a red miss
mcguffin that solves all problems
i think the film is metaphorically
making a comment about men in power
controlling women
and getting them to act against their
will but to me
it would just be much stronger if they
made these decisions on their own
rather than having them just being mind
controlled and then suddenly not anymore
anyway yes just my opinion there but nat
and elena rescue their father alexia out
of prison
and they reunite with molina who we
learned was paramount to the red room
programming
due to her scientific discoveries as a
family they destroyed drakov's
headquarters
which look like a cross between the
triskelion and a helicarrier
elena kills drakov and they bring down
the base with nat having to skydive in
order to save her sister who doesn't
have a parachute
she catches up to her but nat is tracked
by taskmaster and the pair plummet
towards the ground
ner is able to free antonia from the
programming using a vial of red mist
and antonia hugs her whilst asking if
her father is gone
she's finally free and though she could
pop up in the mcu again as taskmaster
i very much view her arc as being over
as she seemed like someone who didn't
want to fight
so it's unlikely she'll be up for
returning to the battlefield anytime
soon
that apologizes not only to her but also
elena
who she feels like she should have gone
back for after her defection
nat decides to stay behind and elena and
cole leave to travel the world freeing
the widows that are still subject to the
red room's mind control
elena gives nat her tactical jacket
which we see the character
wearing in infinity war ross's forces
arrive
and weirdly the movie cuts out rather
than explaining how net managed to get
out the situation
to me this was a very strange thing to
do i think it just seems like they
needed a reason for not to leave the
family
but also didn't know how she would get
out of ross tracking her down
either way though she does and we cut to
two weeks later to see she's still on
the run
thus we know that she didn't agree to
hand herself in
or go back with ross that meets with
rick mason
who throughout the movie provides her
with tech and also transports
he gives her a quinn jet and it is
possible that this is the one that was
found at the end of age of ultron
as we know the one the hulk was in went
as a car with him
now decides to go home and patch things
up and we know that this vehicle was
used by her and the rug avengers during
infinity war
she travels off into the sunset to the
avengers theme and we see
fireflies drifting around a tree this is
symbolic on a number of levels
as we learn in the film that nat's real
mother was killed and she was buried
under a tree like this
it also explains why the post-credits
scene shows that nat's grave is being
placed under one two
and here we see elena visiting it she's
also brought her dog which calls back to
earlier in the movie in which she said
she wanted to get one
and have a normal life she stands there
crying which is when val shows up out of
nowhere
offering her a job clearly from the
dialogue we can tell that the pair of
work together
as elena says val shouldn't be bothering
her on her holiday time
when we last saw the character she was
recruiting john walker
aka u.s agent at the end of falcon in
the winter soldier
now they did switch the release dates up
for this and that was meant to follow
after black widow
but i actually feel that the scene works
a lot better now that we know who she is
knowing the comics val was even a love
interest of nick fury
so it makes sense that she's sort of
taken on his phase one role
in forming the villains dc clearly
rushed justice league in order to catch
up with marvel
and i always hoped that they would have
taken their time with forming the
suicide squad
i really wanted to see the villains in
that pop-up in other movies before they
made it to the team
and it looks like marvel are once again
following their formula and taking their
time
i can see val popping up in a lot of
films and properties in order to pull
the villains together
to either form the dark avengers or
maybe the thunderbolts
bal in the comics ended up becoming
madame hydra and it seems like she's up
to no good
as she says to elena she knows who
killed her sister and presents her with
an image of hawkeye
now we know that there is currently a
disney plus show in the works featuring
the character
and his protege kate bishop this will be
starring haley steinfeld in the role
and it's due to release later this year
according to the wiki florence p
will also be popping up and obviously
this post-credits scene is setting up
their showdown
after the events of end game clint is
probably still viewed in many circles as
a vigilante
as we know he operated as the ronin
during the five years between the snap
in the blip
there are several agencies that likely
won his head and think with elena being
the top assassin in the red room program
that she will have been selected first
for the job obviously we know that he
didn't kill natasha
but this has clearly been twisted so
that elena will hunt him down
however i think that it will be very
much the undoing of val's plan
and elena is obviously aware that her
sister hit out with clint during the
budapest mission
therefore i think hawkeye will convince
her he didn't murder her sister
and she will then join the avengers
taking up the mantle of black widow
much like how she did in the comics val
will then have to get together other
members in order to form her team
and potentially the avengers may track
down the group and go head to head with
them
now before we get into our review if
you've enjoyed the video then please
smash the thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe as we're
going to be dropping a big video going
through all the easter eggs on the movie
very soon
now as for my thoughts on the film i
have to say i was a bit disappointed
i really wanted this to be a movie that
encapsulated natasha's home and how she
inspired those around her
but instead i think it felt a bit hollow
i would have loved to have seen the
budapest mission in full 2
another movie touches upon these aspects
it does seem a bit shallow in terms of
the character depth that we get
the piece very much feels like it's a
yelena bulova origin story
rather than a goodbye to black widow and
i have no idea why it exists because
there's nothing here beyond her
introduction that i feel was all that
substantial
taskmaster and drakov were a big
disappointment for me too
and considering these characters have so
much hype behind them
i was expecting a lot more now the movie
does excel in its action pieces
and these are by far some of the best in
the mcu the corecast do a great job with
florence purely shining
and i feel that scholar johansson gives
her best mc performance thus far
it's just a shame that the stakes are
really low and that the movie feels
meaningless
because we know what comes before and
after for the character
this kinda removes the stakes a bit and
though it's nice finding out what made
nat the way she is
i think they just released this because
fans demanded we finally get a film for
her
rather than the creators actually having
a story to tell
for me it's one of the more forgettable
films in the mcu and i've watched
it three times now and still can't
really tell you what happened in it
overall though i am excited to see what
happens next but unfortunately for me
this movie gets a 6.5 out of 10. now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film so make sure you comment
below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 30th of july
in which we randomly pick three comments
to win an mcu box set of your choice
all you have to do to be with the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now say that to you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
loki episode 5
which will be linked on screen right now
it's absolutely packed with easter eggs
so definitely go check it out and i'll
see you over there without the way
thank you for clicking this i mean ball
take care yourself
peace
you